what is happening reject nation i'm not
feeling 100
john take it away guys we're gonna watch
film
theories uh video glad you're taking it
away john
yes let me find it real quick i had the
window open and everything and now it's
gone this is the film theory dc yeah we
need to
fix your universe all right guys take
two phil we are going to watch today
film theories dear dc
i fixed your universe zack snyder
today so good so good today we're gonna
watch film theories dear dc
i fixed your universe justice league
snyder
cut video i always loved checking out
film theory matpat
has obviously top of the line
work on display he wouldn't be this big
otherwise and
and yeah let's hop into this
today i'm excited to unveil to you my
ultimate theory
one untouched by studio interference one
unburdened by the needs of an algorithm
in this one video i am freed from the
shackles of convention
and can present to you my true artistic
vision
and now for your viewing pleasure my
snyder cut theory
in 360p resolution just as it was always
meant to be watched to preserve
the artist's vision hello internet
welcome to
film theory where the four-hour version
of this episode is currently locked in a
vault waiting for warner brothers to
call and offer us 30 million dollars for
reshoots
well while we wait for that call i
wanted to talk about the newly released
snyder cut version of the 2017 movie
justice league which i will be the first
to admit was
way better than i ever expected i mean
take that with a hefty grain of salt
considering it's like one of the only
movies i've seen in months and the
original was
real bad but hey set the bar low enough
and you have nowhere to go but um
seriously though my bro zach actually
pulled it off and transformed a garbage
fire of a movie
both in terms of plot and coloring into
a real movie with
real characters and real stakes and if
you have no idea what i'm talking about
here's the 30-second catch-up back in
2016
wb and dc were in a rush to catch up
with the massive success marvel was
having with big superhero team-up movies
which you know it's gonna be hard for
them when they had no team
at that point in time they'd only had
one movie man of steel and it wasn't all
that well-received
so it's quite doing solo products right
introducing characters one at a time
they instead tried to do
everything all at once jumping from
here's superman to now that you know
superman here's this guy who dresses up
to punch him also wonder who's here for
reasons and want to see some youtube
clips of these other guys that
may become important at some point also
hallucinations
as you might imagine that movie batman v
superman came out to reviews that
weren't so great but justice league the
immediate sequel
but that's why everyone needs to watch
the bvs
ultimate edition there you go you make
this clear
smooth it out for yourself i get it if
you only watch the theatrical but you
must watch the ultimate
seriously justice league the immediate
sequel a film that's important to
remember was planned to be a
trilogy of movies was already well into
production and set for release the next
year at that point so a bit late to make
any changes there
early test screenings for the first
justice league weren't great and the
studio was already eyeing major reshoots
so
things weren't peachy but they went from
bad to worse when a family tragedy
struck zack snyder
and he had to step down as director
getting replaced with avengers director
joss whedon who
at the studios request tried to change
the tone of the movie to more closely
match dc's more successful rivals
unfortunately the clashing visions of
the two directors made justice league
get at josh sweden's justice league an
awkward final product prompting a huge
fan movement for zack snyder to have the
chance to finish the movie he started
do you remember when joss whedon was a
god
i do i remember when he was untouchable
and now
i know buffy firefly just like let's get
a
whole laundry list of indiscretions
going the avengers
it's just like joss whedon is the
greatest
king of the nerds he knows how to write
characters and ensembles and
deconstructions
and he's woke man hbo max decided to
grant everyone's wish giving zach and
the team an enormous
30 million dollar budget for reshoots
and yeah the movie is out it was like
closer to 70 million or something yeah i
feel like that's where
ultimately around the snyder cut are 73
from critics and 95
from fans 95 they jumped right past
marvel numbers and went straight to
pixar numbers and i gotta say regardless
of how you feel about the movie or dc
or all of that congratulations to zack
snyder i'm sure it is supremely
satisfying to make the movie yeah
to see it get such a positive reception
but most importantly of all finally have
this chapter come to a close
movie that i would guess reminds him of
what was undoubtedly one of the hardest
moments in his life
so are the legions of fans who are
campaigning for this
oh you finally of course not if you give
a mouse a cookie he'll ask you for a
glass of milk now give us the snyder
first
billion dollar film franchise this story
is no longer about
hashtag release the snyder cut the
hashtag is now
written restore the dance which in case
you're not familiar means continuing the
darker established storyline that snyder
had in mind for these films as opposed
to you know
scrapping it all as recent news has
suggested that the studio plans to do
and look i know that other online
commentators out there are annoyed by
even more snyder fans hey tyrone
i think it's totally fine i definitely
don't like the fact that they review
bomb
other movies to get their message out
there how aggressive some of their
tactics are but those are just a few bad
eggs in this group
overall i can't fault people for liking
a series of movies and then dedicating
years of their lives to being fans of
those movies and then being disappointed
when the movies don't reach their proper
conclusion
no one likes an unresolved cliffhanger
that said i'm also here today to tell
those people to save their breath
in fact i'm here to tell them to rejoice
friends spare your tweets the snyder
verse is already restored in fact
it never left no matter what they say
publicly about having no plans to move
forward that's exactly what they're
doing
for this to happen but i'm not talking
about this just from a sneaky business
perspective the proof
is actually in the new snyder cut of
justice league you heard me right the
snyder cut version of justice league is
actually canon to the established dc eu
in fact
not only is it canonical it serves as
the good ending to the complete snyder
vs story
so today i want to put the issue to rest
because in my mind both the theatrical
cut and the snyder cut can fit into the
larger dc
eu if and only if wb and dc have the
cojones to do it so first things first
it's important to understand that coming
up on dc's future releases
yeah it's been established for a while
now that this movie will be inspired by
the flashpoint
storyline in the comics in which barry
allen the flash goes back in time to
save his mother from being murdered by
his arch nemesis the reverse flash now
not to go on too much of a tangent here
but john broome
the dc writer who created the reverse
flash he must have just phoned this one
in hard
just imagine his manager bursting into
his office one day like we need a bad
guy for the flash and john was like uh
reversed just like the flash but yellow
where red should be
in red where yellow should be anyway by
saving his mother barry accidentally
alters reality
in major ways
hey it's hilarious but reverse flash is
a cool character man he's a cool
character
you know it's the origins aside things
can grow into wonderful things that
their names maybe don't hint
yeah i personally think reverse flash
makes her a very
intimidating presence i can't imagine
the flash world without him
but it is it does sound lazy depending
on the context you put in
there's the five minutes before the
meeting sort of decision right there
opposite flesh barry accidentally alters
reality in some major ways but only he
can notice for everyone else things have
just always been this different guys
should watch that dc animated movie we
need to use the flashlight
in the comics to make some major changes
and fix their continuity
clearing away the unpopular characters
and storylines to make room for the
things that audiences liked
hmm now why does this all sound like the
perfect thing for dc to do at this point
in time
what we've with their predicting the
fact that as of right now they have four
completely disconnected projects all
featuring batman joker snyder's justice
league
justice league and robert pattinson's
batman
that's not confusing and bloated at all
or maybe it's the fact that according to
wonder woman director patty jenkins even
the movie directors at this point are
ignoring the whedon
era version of justice league despite wb
still holding firm that
that is the canonical timeline i mean i
could go on with more reasons why this
franchise might need a universal reset
at this point but i think you get it and
while i say it's a solo movie it's
really shaping up to be a multiverse
movie akin to into the spider-verse
during last year's dc fan dome event
which it's worth noting had 100 hours of
streaming content about their upcoming
projects available for
get this one day 24 hours so i hope
you're watching everything at three
times
the team working on the new flash movie
revealed the fact that not just
one but too bad would be appearing in it
both ben affleck's batman from the
current gen of movies as well as michael
keaton who played batman and tim
burton's original 1989 blockbuster
the two batman the kill that's right
yeah
the only ones for me my batman kills
exclusively sure high top films is very
excited about that this strongly
indicates that flashpoint will be
dealing not just with time travel
through
dc's multiverse it's the exact thing
that snyder's new movie already is
heavily alluding to
the anti-life the key to controlling
all life and all will throughout the
multiverse and i think you can start
[Music]
that that's totally fine over my head
well you know it's it's one moment out
of a four-hour movie but that is a
pretty big moment right now
ah damn i've been through the movie
twice now i failed
i failed failed your i failed i owe zack
snyder
50 000 would that technically have been
the first
actual hint at the multiverse uh
it seems like it is the most blatant one
wow
that totally flew over my head
and does flash time travel and i think
you can start to see where i'm going
with this
of course the snyder versus canon
whether explicitly or not
when practically everything is going to
be validated in this upcoming multiverse
movie that's how you have two different
justice leagues both canon at the same
time
but you know multiverses are the easy
way out i actually want to take it one
step further i want to show you that
snyder's new timeline is
actually one in the same with the
original and established dc continuity
it is canonical
with the justice league movie they're
all a continuation of the exact
same story the snyder cut is the good
ending to our adventure let me explain
you see when you have nearly twice as
much movie to fill you can do things
like
fill it with icelandic song breaks and
an egregious amount of moody staring but
in that extra amount of time you can
also make some pretty radical
alterations to a movie's original story
including prophecies and extended
epilogues set in the ruined wastelands
of earth devastated by the attacks of
dark side and evil superman
this is the nightmare future that's a
night with a k
get it as in the dark knight anyway in
this thing we see wonder woman dead
aquaman dead flash is a hardened warrior
and batman teaming up with the joker
so what where's all this coming from
well
this was always meant to be a core
element in zack snyder's justice league
trilogy back when it was supposed to be
a three movie series in snyder's
original vision for justice league 2
which he's been very public about
superman would give bruce wayne the job
of protecting lois
lois and bruce would begin to have a lot
of affairs
certainly and one that apparently was
rejected by the studio so
at least they showed some good judgment
there anyway during a crucial moment
bruce would
do you think at one point bruce was
making love to lois and then lois was
like oh
clark and he was like is my daddy's name
oh there you go or maybe bruce is also
making love to clark in his mouth
yeah he just doesn't want to get caught
begin to have a love affair which is
a choice certainly and one that
apparently was rejected by the studio so
at least they showed some good judgment
there anyway during the crucial moment
bruce would hesitate
resulting in lois's death i want that
story to turn into the dark side brought
on by
darkseid in justice league three batman
and the remaining team would build a
device the cosmic treadmill which would
allow flash to travel back to the past
warn bruce about darkseid and stress the
importance of saving lois's life thereby
changing the future and we see that this
nightmare future
does come true in visions throughout the
snyder cut we see superman
cradling a burnt body presumably lowest
inside of the bat cave as evidenced by
the robin suit hidden in the back
the nightmare is real we actually hear
it from the joker himself
you need me to help you undo this world
you created by letting her die
how many alternate timelines do you
destroy the world because
you don't have the colonies to die
yourself the question though is in what
universe is the dark nightmare future
happening
well i firmly believe based on the
evidence in all of these movies that the
nightmare is the result of joss whedon's
justice league
dark side superman turning evil it's all
the continuation of
justice league and what the canon dc eu
is headed towards when the flash
moves and goes to war in the past that
sets up the snyder stories
batman v superman and his version of
justice league
create a second timeline the one that
does things right and actually manages
to save the earth but how can we be sure
about this
original cut of justice league bruce
wayne has no idea about lois lane being
the key to anything he doesn't comment
on his prophecies he doesn't mention his
dreams he doesn't mention lois lane
at all compare that to the snyder cut
where he actively talks about his dreams
with diana
i had a dream barry allen was right here
and he said to me
lois lane is the key this is a reference
to the flash's warning in batman v
superman
which is clearly happening on the second
timeline
after these events have already
transpired once because he wasn't
worried about that
in a relationship with superman nothing
special to take note of
it would make sense that this version of
batman would drop the ball on protecting
her
or as the joker says why you sent a boy
wonder
to do a man's job but in the snyder cut
bruce is
keenly aware of lois outright commenting
on her being pregnant with superman's
baby
congratulations by the way and it's all
because of the warning that he received
from the future
in addition the first version of justice
league shows us a much more fragmented
team
even as he goes out into the last battle
batman just barks out the order
don't wait for me just do the job when
he gets saved by the rest of the league
cyborg indicates that it wasn't a team
decision hey blame the lady
we would have left you but she didn't
ask for a vote this indicates that the
mainline dc eu justices
oh the snyder lying justice league which
is why we see them fighting
and dying to dark side solo in the
nightmare hallucinations
further proof this comes from the joker
references throughout the nightmare
in the snyder cuts epilogue we see joker
give bruce a truce card
as long as you have this card the truce
but all you have to do is tear a nap and
i'm happy to discuss with you in any way
like why you sent a boy wonder
to do a man's job it's a symbol of them
putting aside their differences to be a
team and in batman v superman we
actually see bruce with that card taped
to his gun
however in the scene of superman lording
over the fallen remains of the heroes we
see the joker's card
torn batman broke the truce a weak team
ultimately leads to the destruction of
humanity
mostly driven by batman's ego or
superman lasered the [ __ ] out of batman
yeah and the card got a little caught in
the crossbar although it was perfectly
split in half
well hey man those laser eyes that's
really straight being
in a superman laser obliterate the whole
thing you would think so
yeah that's true all right theory proven
a weak team ultimately leads to the
destruction of humanity
mostly driven by batman's ego meanwhile
the snyder cut shows us a team that
cares much more about each other with
barry specifically caring a lot about
bruce wayne
are you okay bruce
there's also smaller details here too
like how in the nightmare visions
aquaman is killed by a three-pronged
trident
that's the trident of atlan the one that
we see him accept in the aquaman movie
which is a canonical continuation of
joss whedon's justice league and we know
it based on a few details first the
events of both films in the snyder cut
mira's parents are explicitly stated as
being dead
my parents died in the wars however in
the aquaman movie her father plays a
significant role in the events that
transpired
additionally we have ourselves mira's
accent here is how mira talks in aquaman
your half-brother king orm is about to
declare war upon the surface world
billions will die here's how she sounds
in the original
justice league it would have been her
responsibility to follow that monster to
the surface and stop it
now it's yours
and here's her completely different
accent from the snyder cut
it would have been her responsibility to
follow that monster to the surface and
stop him
now it's yours
there's also the flash in justice league
barry has no confidence
in fact he outright says that he's never
done battle before full transparency
i've never done battle
i've just pushed some people and run
away his whole arc in that entire story
is that he needs to save just one
person save one what
save one person compare that to the
snyder cut where barry is not only
saving people and hot dogs on the
regular but already knows how to use his
extreme speed to manipulate time to such
a degree that he can catch the exact
moment
a mother box hits the water in batman v
superman we see a barry who's trying to
travel through time but
misses his target date
that would make sense if it was the
first time that he was testing out time
travel powers pushing his limits only
because of a severe need for survival
but the snyder cuts flash
is honed in his time travel skills which
also makes sense
if this is the second go-around for this
universe but the biggest detail that
confirms all of this is the fact that in
the justice league no one knows who
darkseid is unlike the snyder cut which
ends with the team facing him down and
martian manhunter issuing a warning to
bruce justice league has nothing the
team has no frame of reference that
steppenwolf works for an even bigger bad
as such they will be preparing for this
massive alien invasion and without
batman's investment into lois lane's
well-being darkseid will have little
problem
killing her turning superman evil this
darkest
timeline will lead barry allen on the
cosmic treadmill and try to go back in
time to alert batman and create the
alternate snyder line
where they actually have a chance to
save the universe in short the nightmare
epilogue created by zack snyder in his
movie
is dunking on the original cut basically
calling it
the failed ending of his storyline this
is what happens to the characters whose
stories continue on
first of all i would have loved it if
this was wp's original please
yes
my question is and maybe you guys can
clarify where matpat's theory is coming
from i like what he's saying is that the
the change in events happen from bvs
when flash goes and sees bruce
is what matpat sang that injustice
league
that never happened for that bruce wayne
is that what he's saying because i'm
like well
it still comes after the theatrical cut
of bbs and bbs he does
still show up flash it's just bruce
never brings it up in justice league i
mean on the timeline
matpat had bvs coming on to the one
timeline after the the actual moment
where barry travels through time and
talks to bruce so i almost feel like
he's like splitting
both justice leagues at that exact
moment or something because that's in
that movie so either way it's in the
text of both like that's yeah one detail
that is confusing because it seems like
bruce got the message either way
and i guess then is justice league just
the version where he didn't take it that
seriously and
yeah this is the version where he's like
oh damn no this is really oh yeah we had
to screw this up once for me to realize
no this is important
yeah i think that's maybe what it is or
something
okay it's still hurting my brain yeah i
know yeah it's a lot to keep up with
that but i feel like you can make a
bottom line it's still coming down to
multiverse
i'm remembering now that uh christ on
infinite earth they established the
multiverse when ezra miller met with
grant gustin and all that
so seeds planted
the team falls apart this in turn sets
up the snyder cut to not only be canon
but also be the good conclusion of
everything that came before
correcting the mistakes that were made
in the past which come to think of it is
insanely meta considering that's how
these movies themselves shaped up to be
the long and short of it is this dc
listen to me sit down
on the couch and actually listen to me
because sometimes you don't know what's
good for you
you have yourselves a real shot here to
please fans without totally backtracking
on all your movies
you have yourself a win here served up
on a silver platter
don't blow it because not even
flashpoint will be able to erase
another misstep like that but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and cut
but what's confusing to me too
yes that's a great image by the way
what's confusing to me too
is in zack snyder's justice league
martian manhunter shows up at the end so
it's setting up so he's saying like keep
both going
mm-hmm they saying essentially keep both
i'm all for the multiverse and i want
them to restore the snyder verse but
it's like i also want them to kind of
keep some of what they're already doing
going
you know like yeah like i like the
direction of where the suicide squad
looks like it's going and harley quinn
and yeah i wanted aquaman too
it does make me wonder what the ultimate
it seems like it still would rely on
flashpoint to
establish what now the continuity is in
light of all this
stuff but it does seem especially given
just the order
things have been released in that yeah
you could make that argument of like
okay here's the way it went horribly
wrong
and now here's the way it goes right
like it's still a bit funny i guess
because both movies have a resolution
that in their
you know respective films is like oh
yeah we won i guess just saving the
russian family is gonna set up a much
more grim future than
you know doing everything we did with
steppenwolf and darkseid and whatnot
yeah i mean it does seem at least like
an opportunity to
really look at what the best is of every
iteration of these characters they've
put out until now and you can keep
all the what like you could keep the
entire justice league based off of this
and it would still work
all right well i'm down for it i hope
stages
listen to this what i like what i like
about it is you don't
have to do too much extra cause it seems
like to restore the snyder verse that
might be somewhere where the creative
woes are coming in
of i just said we got to do a lot more
changing and
but no not really it's like what i think
what matpat did was go no you already
have it established here with this one
specific plot point
and you can and by working off of that
just a little bit you can have your your
versions uh
carrying onward do you like the way this
is shaping up let me know
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
hashtag restore the damn snide reverse
people
last but not least
deontay w tongue punch fart box normally
when we shout out deontay there's always
some
joke about your tongue punch fart box
name but how many of those can you
really do so
it's like what does the name deonte mean
you were
strong in material matters determined
and stubborn ooh like
whenever you put your tongue
up against someone's farts
and the materials just
just let's get it into that sentence
what does the material do
does it turn into something i was gonna
go sincere but i was like i think
there's an opportunity for a fart
company
yeah no my juvenile mind can't finish
you're strong
in material matters of farts you're
determined to punch
them and you're stubborn about which
boxes you allow them to go it seems like
you are aptly
named neon man combine all three of them
and
unlock the the the you know there's got
to be like a fart related
version of yeah it would have been funny
yeah we should
[Music]